المترجم: Muna Kambal
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
أنا عرفت دكتور أنور كان يقول لي لدينا هنا
متحدث عن أمدرمان فنرجو أن لا تكثري
وقد سمعنا في الاول ودخلنا في التاريخ
تحدثنا عن السرد التاريخي عن أمدرمان
وعرفنا معلومات عديدة، أحياءها وتسمياتها
وإنتقلنا من التاريخ الى الرياضة وأنا أرى
ثلاث ارباع من هم هنا من الشباب
وحديث الرياضة معهم جيد جداً هذا الشيء
ومع هذا الحديث عن أمدرمان أود أن أقول
لكم مازال لدينا فيها بعض المشاكل
صديقة لي في يوم من الايام قالت لي : لما
لا نخرج ونذهب للخرطوم لأنكم هنا لا تملكون
أماكن للخروج في أمدرمان وشوارعكم
ضيقه جداً وليس لديكم أي شيء
وهذا الحديث أغضبني جداً واكثر ما أغضبني،
أنها قالت لي أنتي درستي تخطيط! هل تذهبي
للجامعة كل يوم وليس لديك علاقة بهذا الشيء
أعملوا يا إخوتي فأنتم مخططين إشتغلوا
وأعملوا، وقد أحزنني هذا الشيء وضايقني،
بدأت أحصر المشاكل التي لدينا
الأحياء لا أحد يستطيع الحديث عنها لانها
قديمة، مثلاً لا أستطيع القول يجب أن نعيد
تخطيط منطقة بيت المال التي أنتمي اليها
فأكثر شئ يمكن أن نشتغل عليها هى الشوارع
ويوجد شارع لي معه قصة ألا هو الشارع الذي
مرت به في دراستي منذ أن كنت بالإبتدائية
الى أن وصلت الجامعة وهو أيضاً تاريخي وقد
ذكره الدكتور أنفاً شارع "بوابة عبدالقيوم"،
فلا أود الحديث عنه هنا فقط أسمحوا لي القول
بأنه بقعه داخل البقعة، وكفى! وللناس الذين
لا يعرفونه، هو شارع موازي لشارع النيل
والذي يقاصد صالة الثريا هذه والذي بيدأ
هو شارع إتجاهه شمال جنوب ويبدأ من منطقة
سجن النساء أمدرمان مروراً ببعض المرافق
العامة والتعليمية مثل مدرسة أحمد بشير
العبادي، سكن الطالبات ومستشفى الدايات
وهي من أقدم المستشفيات هنا ومن ثم البقعة
التي تحدثت لكم عنها وتتبع لبوابة عبدالقيوم
وينتهي في تقاطع الرفيرا والذي هو هنا
بالقرب منا وهذا الموقع يمكن أن اقول لكم
شرقه يوجد حي الملازمين القديم وجنوبه حي
الموردة، حسناً إخوتي ما مشكلة هذا الشارع
أنا أتي يومياً ماره بهذا الشارع، والمشكلة
هي زحمة المرور بهذة المنطقة
من ساعات الصباح الاولى وتوجد أوقات ذروات
لو تركنا الذروة وتحدثنا عن ساعات الصباح
الاولى، مدرسة أحمد بشيرالعبادي إزدحامها
يبدا من حوالي الساعة 8 الي 9 تقف التراحيل،
داخلية البنات من حدود الساعة 8 الي 11 ص،
مستشفى الدايات تقريباً إزدحامها 24 ساعة
تجد المواصلات العامة واقفه، وأماكن وقوف
السيارات الخاصة والأجرة والذي يقل فيه
الضغط في ساعات المساء المتأخرة وأيضا
الداخلية بنفس الشئ. أوقات الذروة وقتين لا
يمر الشخص بهذه المنطقة إلا ولاقى الإزدحام،
الساعة الصباحية من 8-11 والمسائية من 2-5
هذة أكثر أماكن فيها إزدحام
والمشكلة بهذا الشارع والذي لم أصفه لكم
هذا الشارع إتجاهين وكل إتجاه به مسارين
والشارع الرئيسي لبوابة عبدالقيوم
عرضه 30 متر، عفواً إخوتي
ومع مرور الزمن نقص هذا الشارع نسبة لان
التربه تحركت، وحصل الضيق كما يقول
المثل الذي عندنا "هذا الشخص أكل عليه الدهر
وشرب" وهذا ما حصل لهذا الشارع ايضاً
وقد ضاق الشارع، وقبل سنين طويلة خضع لحلول
قديمه، تم إزالة منطقة الجزيرة التي بالوسط
كي يتوسع الشارع ولكن حصلت مشكلة هنا، الا
وهي بعض التخطي من السيارات وهنا السودانيون
لا يصبرون لاي شئ، فمثلاً إذا كانت هنالك
عربة منتظرة وأريد أن أمر، فسوف أتخطاها
وهذة المشكلة أدت لحوادث كثيرة وممكن عادي
تجد شخص سائق في المسار الذي بالوسط فيدخل
للمسار الثاني، وأقرب حاجة حصلت كانت
في شهر1 الفائت قبل 4 او 3 أسابيع
حيث حصل حادث لطالبة من طالبات الداخلية
ومن بعده حدثت تعديلات بالشارع ومنها خلال
أسبوعين وضعت علامات تحديد السرعة والمرور،
خطوط المشاة على الأرض وأيضاً وضعت مطبات
بالقرب من المدرسة والداخلية كبعض الحلول
للتقلل من الضغط والحوادث على هذة المنطقة
حسناً المشكلة الثانية هي المواقف، أكثر شيء
محزن هنا ان تجد مركبات الطلبة تقف في جزء
من الشارع من شدة إزدحام المنطقة،
وبالذات أمام المستشفى، الظاهرة للجميع
والناس كثيراً كانوا يتضايقون من هذا الشيء
فالمدرسة لها وقت محدد الى الساعة 5 وكل
مركبات الترحيل تتحرك، ولكن المشكلة كانت
هذا المكان، أنا أنفاً لم اذكر لكم أن هذة
المنطقة تحوي مسارين للمواصلات ويجب
على الأقل أن يحوي إشارة مرور لتخفف
من هذه المشكلة، وكما أخبرتكم أنفاً، أنا
مخططة ويفترض أن أعمل في هذا المجال
واقترح حلولاً يمكن تنفيذها، إذا نفذت ام لم
تنفذ، كي يرى الشوارع منظمة كما درستها
أكاديمياً وأطبقها على أرض الواقع، الا وهي
الاشياء التي ذكرتها بسبب حوادث كثيرة ظهرت
لنا، مثل المطبات، إشارات المرور والعلامات
هذه مطلوبه، ثانياً مشكلة المواقف فبما أن
الشارع ضيق، المواقف تكون طولية لان الشارع
لا يتحمل عمل شيء كهذا، ومن ثم نقاط التجمع
يا إخوتي نقاط التجمع موجودة في اي بلد،
والناس هنا لم يفهموها صح وقد تم إنشاءها
عندنا هنا قبل سنين، مواقف البصات التي تم
ترقيمها وتنظيمها كي تقف في المنطقة معينة
وتنقل الناس، ولكن هنا لم نستخدمها، فأكثر
شئ يزهق الشخص أن تجد صاحب المركبة يقف
في منتصف هذا المكان الضيق والمزدحم
لكي ينزل أحد الركاب، وهذة هي المشكلة
ويمكن حلها بعمل نقطين في هذه المنطقة قبل
وبعد الإزدحام كي تخفف من الضغط،
والشيء الاخر تحويل المسار، قلت أن 3 خطوط
مواصلات تمر بهذة المنطقة، المتجهة الخرطوم
المتجهة سوق ليبيا والاخرى الى سابلة التي
تعرفونها فيمكن تحويل مسار خط الخرطوم
لشارع الإذاعة وتمر بشارع النيل الذي
أمامنا حالياً وتطلع على الريفيرا لتخفف ضغط
تلك المنطقة، وبعد ذلك كباري المشاة وقد
درسنا في تصميم المدارس يجب أن يتوفر في
تصميمها بالذات الإبتدائية منها، كبري
المشاة، في أي تصميم مدرسة يجب وضع الكبري
يمكن أن يتكون موزعة على طول الشارع
وأذكر أنني قدمت مقترح هنا عن المستشفى
سابقاً، وواجهت إستغراباً بنقلها من المكان
إنها مستشفي قديمة لها تاريخ لا يمكن نقلها
ولكن تنقل لسبب، فإستخدامها ليس له علاقة
ببقية المرافق كالمدرسة والداخلية التي تخدم
الطلاب بمراحلهم العمرية المختلفة مما يعني
أن المستشفى لاعلاقة لها بهذه الأشياء
إذن ماذا سنستفيد من الموقع الحالي الذي
ننقلها منه، وبعد أن نقلنا المستشفى ووفرنا
كل سبل الوصول اليها، أماكن إنتظار، المعمل
والصيدلية وتم تنظيمها، فماذا نعمل بالمنطقة
السابقة، ننشء مواقف إنتظار، فهل هكذا حُلت
المشكلة؟ لا لم أعمل شيء، فقد رأيتم العربي
وتلك المناطق وكيف إزدحامها، لا لا، شئ مخطط
ومصمم بطريقة وبمقاييس العالمية بمداخلها
ومخارجها، شيء مسور ومنظم جدأً جداً هنا
لتحل مشكلة وجود المواصلات بهذا الشارع
ومن ثم يوضع لها مخرجها الخاص، حسناً TEDx
أمدرمان عنوانه "ماذا نريد الأن" وبعد حديثي
الكثيرهذا وعن المواصلات والزحمة ومثل هذه
الأشياء، ماذا نريد الأن ولماذا نتستمع اليك
منذ فترة، نحن نحتاج عندما يطلع الشخص
الصباح الى عمله أولاحقاً إجتماعاً ما،
لايصل زهقان أويعصب في الموظفين الذين معه
وأن يصل في وقته ويصل مرتاح نفسياً
محتاجين للطالب الذي يحصل محاضرته الصباح
أن لا يطرده الدكتور لوجود مشكلة ما بالشارع
وهذه حصلت لي كثيراً، محتاجين للأمات الذين
يلبسوا أطفالهم الصباح ليطلعوا، يحسوا
بالامان، يا إخوتي هولاء هم جيل المستقبل،
أن تحس الأم بأن طفلها سوف يذهب ويعود
اليها سالماً، ليس فقط في شارع بوابة
عبدالقيوم او في شوارع أمدرمان ولا في شوارع
العاصمة المثلثة بل في شوارع بلدنا جميعها
محتاجين تنظيمها بطريقة صحيحة وإن شاء الله
دائماً نرى السودان في أفضل صورة.
وشكراً لكم
(تصفيق)